hey did you know that tensorflow now
supports JavaScript well if you didn't
now you do stay tuned to find out how to
run tensorflow on the most widely used
programming language in the world
[Music]
welcome to cloud AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng Guo
and on this episode we'll unpack
tensorflow j/s a little bit and show you
some of the amazing things that you can
do with it I'm sure you'll come up with
your own epic use cases by the end of
this so let's dive right in tensorflow
TAS lives at JSC tensorflow org there
you can find all the documentation
tutorials and links to awesome examples
the tutorials really do a great job of
layering on top of each other building
up your tensorflow J's skills start at
the top of the page and work your way
down one by one along the way you'll
train a convolutional neural network in
your browser and create a pacman game
that you can play with data you record
with your webcam so what else have
people made with tensorflow gjs well for
one there's Poe's net which does a
pretty impressive job and identifying
your position in an image okay so that's
silliness aside what else is tensorflow
that jay is good for well you can import
your tensorflow and caris models
directly into the browser now this
enables you to train complex models with
large data sets just like you're used to
doing and then bring those models
straight into the browser and we'll
actually see an example of that in a
future episode of AI adventures so keep
your eye out now if you really want to
get fancy you can take an imported model
in tensorflow jeaious and then further
train it
so imagine loading in an existing a
state-of-the-art research model and then
adding some of your own training data to
specialize that model in some way maybe
with image
is from the webcam so some of you may be
wondering hey what's the relationship
between tensorflow jeaious and this
other library deep learned rjs well
tensorflow GS is a whole ecosystem of
JavaScript tools for machine learning
and it actually evolved from deep
learned is that portion is now known as
Tessa flow das core the rest of
tensorflow das features additional
functionality and tools to help make
doing machine learning in JavaScript
easier another big question around doing
machine learning with JavaScript his
performance anecdotally for predictions
tensorflow Jas with WebGL is about one
and a half to two times slower then
tensorflow using Python with AVX
enabled on the training side we've seen
that large models train actually 10 or
even 15 times slower in the browser
compared with tensorflow on Python so
while it's unlikely that tensorflow
digest will completely replace the raw
performance of server-side training
there are some amazing experiences to be
created via client-side machine learning
this was just the quick overview of
tensorflow das I was super excited at
the fact that this is out in the wild so
I really needed to get this to you so
you can get started as soon as possible
we will spend some more time with
tensorflow das in future episodes and
look at some tips and tricks in more
detail thanks for watching this episode
of cloud AI adventures and if you
enjoyed it please hit that like button
and subscribe to get all the latest
episodes right when they come out for
now head on over to Jas tensorflow org
and get started today